ellen appalled Eleanor sells a topper
sailing dinghy and a national level she
has just been selected for the royal
yachting association and Sport England
topper UK junior squad based on her
performance this year Ellen have
finished the 2014 top and national
series as the 14th place girl and the
second under-14 girl in a fleet of 88
girls from across the UK she was also
selected to attend the irish national
topper event from the 4th to the 6th of
july this year in ireland as part of the
british sailing team of nine children
selected nationally Ellie Ingham hill
Ellie has had an incredible year in just
one season she has progressed through
each stage of talent pathway and is now
part of the England under 15s
development program Ellie's progression
in cricket this season includes
captaining the South Devon under 15s
vice-captain for Devon under 15s she
played for the Devon under-17s and the
Devon under-19s was selected and
traveled to Cheshire with Devon ladies
and was selected to play in the england
women's development program under 15
super threes competition in Berkshire
Molly cannon molly is a budding athlete
from newton abbot athletics club she has
had another very successful season
culminating her being ranked first for
800 meters for the 2014 season and also
now beating the all-time 800-meter
record for her age which had been in
place for over a decade Molly's other
accolades include a gold and a silver at
the devon county championships in 800
metres and 200 metres at the southwest
championships and was then selected to
run for devon in the cross county in two
counties championships in Birmingham